Alright guys, so in this lecture I'm gonna show you how I personally use ABCD trading strategy and trust me guys, this is like I would say even powerful than ABC. If we used properly and I'm gonna show you how to use it properly. So how do I use ABCD trading strategy? First of all, as I said before, I look at the overall market structure.
or are we bearish okay once I know the direction of the market so I look back
30 days or 20 days and if the market is going up I look for loans and if the
market has been going down for the past 30 days I only shot guys that is one
in Peru to identify trends. So you have a, b, c, right? You look for
D-leg, okay? And after that, you look for market structure shift on a smaller
time frame. Okay, so there could be structure here. Now unlike, so in ABC strategy, we look for
market structure shift above the range or below the range. Okay, but in ABCD, what can happen is
as long as this level is not broken, you can look for market structure shifts.
And while this level gets broken, you can still look for market structure shifts.
If the trend is bullish, right, this level can act as a liquidity level as well.
But most of the time, the pattern is going to look like this.
A B C D. The D leg takes out the low of the B leg and then you look at the market
such shift on a smaller timeframe. So the recommended timing, the timing that I use, the
timeframe that I use for the strategy is for our and 15 minutes. Okay. And guys trust me,
I'm not lying.
This is like the best time frame to use these strategies.
So on the four hour you look at the market structure
and you identify the ABC pattern.
And after that you look for the del egg
that takes out the low of the b leg.
Once that low is taken out,
you drop down to 15 minutes time frame
and then you look for market structure shift
with displacement that has favorably gap
before market structure shift.
And you take your entry during kill zone ours, okay?
As explained in the ABC video,
I have shown the timings, you must follow that timing.
And you take your entry and you can look for one to two,
target some fairly good gap here.
Probably there is a supplies on our auto block
with very very good gap.
Your flush target would be that.
You would take some partial,
you'd take some partial along the way.
And probably you could be treating your stop loss.
It really depends on your risk management style.
So similarly, if we have a downtrend for the past 30 days or 20 days, you look for a purge
of this level.
So we have a, b, c and this D leg takes out the high of the B leg right here.
Once that is taken out, you look for market structure shift on 15 minute timeframe and yeah,
it's gonna break out perfectly.
Now, sometimes what I do
to make it even more perfect,
I would look for an ABC pen like that,
and I'll use the fib from the start of a leg
and the end of C leg.
And if the delay comes into 0.705 level of 5 or 0.79 level,
right, and then gives you a market structure shift,
then guys, that is an A plus setup I would say.
Okay, I mean, the previous setup is also A plus,
but this adds in more confidence, right?
And if there is a perfect auto block with free value gap
around this level, then, oh, guys, trust me,
you're gonna love when this trade's gonna play out
in your favor.
So your low-per-market switch is shift on 15 minutes.
One price touches the 0.75 or 0.79 level
or an auto block around this area, right?
And I could say 0.5 above the 0.5 level
if you find an auto block or this, these levels,
the ODE levels 0.7 and 0.75.
You look for Microsoft Shift and you take your entry targeting
favorite gaps or auto blocks.
So let me give you guys a couple of examples.